what's up everyone we are gonna be
talking about reaching your divinity I
am with Jessica and healt Welker again
what's up jessica has a lot of cool
videos herself we'll have some links in
the bio for you guys to check out her
work so ok reaching your divinity
there's a lot to talk about Anne unpack
in this we are not experts by any means
in this whatsoever but we have
definitely started uncovering quite a
bit of interesting knowledge wisdom in
this field so now we're gonna share some
of it with you
ok this analogy that we've been using
recently is Marco Polo so the gate in
the game Marco Polo you say the word
Marco and then the person says polo and
then you know you don't see your eyes
are closer then you have to hear where
polo came from and go to in the
direction of polo and then say Marco
again and then here polo and then go in
the direction of polo again so that's
how the game is played so jessica has
this really good analogy of how it
relates to finding our divinity yeah and
that's actually it's not my idea
something that I channeled so something
that I came from the Divine Feminine
that I channeled in that you know we're
all seeking right we're seeking the
divine the divine is always there is
available for us and whether you call it
source spirit consciousness prime
creator divine creator god goddess
whatever it is still that that thing
that we all are kind of internally
seeking whether we're available we're of
it or not and I understand there's some
people who don't believe in this and I
get it but for those of you who do
there's a GPS system in all of us we can
imagine our soul is as GPS as guiding us
through the light following the lights
the blinking lights getting us back to
the divine and so my understanding of it
from what I've channeled is that yeah so
we are seeking we are the Markos and we
are seeking polo and as we're traversing
through our life so you are obstacles
through our difficulties and we're
crying out to polo or crying out and
we're saying we're waiting to hear where
it is and then we move our way to polo
and my understanding is that as we get
closer as we get closer to polo it
starts going from polo polo polo - polo
polo polo it's getting louder and louder
and then the resin is it's deeper the
vibration is higher and your feeling for
me absolutely more and more like yes
this is exactly how I meant to be going
yep and I think a lot of that has to do
with self actualization this whole
process of discovering what your gifts
are and how you're going to give them to
the world so for me for me I definitely
did not feel like I was unpacking and
discovering my gifts when I was working
in all of the previous jobs that I
thought that I've had until most
recently unpacking work with my science
comedy show and simulation now that I
have finally figured out what my gift is
and what I want to bring to the world
and so that process of discovery it
takes a lot of risk it takes a lot of
work of going and trying new things and
and turning off connections to a lot of
things that are distractions it's a very
difficult process and a lot of things
like meditation and psychedelics and
spirituality can definitely guide us
help guide us in that direction of where
polo is and you can literally hear it
like Jessica said you could hear it
becoming louder as you feel closer and
closer to your divinity to your
self-actualization and your gifts that
you're giving to the world you can hear
getting louder and you feel literally
better you feel like your soul and your
spirit is unleashing into the world and
so let's get there and let's figure out
how to build the right systems for
future generations to get there
yeah so just a little bit about me I was
actually in corporate America for 20
years
and I literally walked away from
everything and walked away from my
relationships from where I was where I
was living and I booked a one-way ticket
to Ecuador and it was amazing because I
was actually divinely guided there I was
just following my intuition like I said
that soul GPS and I was on my path and
then what has transpired in the last two
months has been amazing it's nothing
short to me of a miracle really really
truly is that I've been doing that and
so one of the things I've learned is
that plant medicine sacred plant
medicine it is a vehicle for you to get
faster and closer to - polo is it's an
opportunity for you to transcend all of
these things that keep us held down and
feel so dense here on this planet that
we're able to transcend that ascend and
get much much closer to the divine and I
can promise you that I am so much more
joyful and so much more blissful he says
it I've got people coming up to me and
they're asking me whatever it is you're
doing I want to know is it yoga is it
Pilates oh no actually its own sacred
plant medicine I'm enjoying it that I'm
journeying I'm learning and
understanding it and that's the thing
you guys is that how much time do we
have to not live the life were meant to
be living how much time do we have you
know for me I'm so committed like Alan
said so commit to my path I walked away
from everything and I was willing to do
it and because I know that what we are
all meant to do here is so important it
is so important and I promise you you
cannot fail it will not happen but you
will feel that call and things are gonna
start happening in your life they're
either gonna help you move you in that
direction and they might come to you as
challenges obstacles tragedies whatever
it is but it's it is your soul that's
trying to get you back on to the your
path to who you really are and
remembering that Jessica started going
to taking us also in the direction of
what happens as you get closer and
closer to polo well there is a feeling
of this further and further connection
towards the divine towards your
actualization that slowly starts
creeping up and making a bigger bigger
feeling and so when I guess the question
that like you know how stress can see
what she thinks about this is well what
happens when you get really really close
can you
reach your full mark oh can you ever
reach Marco and what does that dealer
look like so there are people who have
achieved enlightenment right they have
achieved self actualization they've
achieved enlightenment and made them
have become you know Buddhas and
whatever they've gone over there's
others who choose to stay on this this
earth and help others get to Polo you
know they they live their life by that
and then there's others who live lives
before they've already achieved and
they're here just to chill out you know
bearwitness love people you know
whatever it is so it comes down to for
me is how far are you willing to go how
far you willing to go to connect to the
divine to what lengths are you willing
to do it that's good and will it be
worth it for you so it's actually really
interesting because to that Instagram
post right that comment so along lengths
are you willing to go to get to Polo I
like that yeah what links are you
willing to go to and there's people
there like spirituality is [ __ ] that
there's no evidence to prove that
there's something divine there and I in
yet I'm like you know what I'm feeling
joyful so does it have to be evidence if
we're arriving at this place within
ourselves a full self potential and self
actualization then being able to go out
and live in the world as we're meant to
be as we were created to be not what
others have told us to be and how to be
but you finding it for yourself and
understanding what your truth is and how
you want to show up in the world that to
me that's good that's good
so basically when other people tell you
how to show up in the world how culture
how mainstream media how your parents
how all these different influences tell
you you have to do it this way this is
the right way to do it when all those
influences tell you to do that
it is deterring you away from finding
polo it's like a distraction polo that's
occurring but it's not the real polo
yeah and and and also so many people are
unconscious about that right
so it's not to say that people are
purposely I mean
there are different different avenues
about that definitely unconscious you
know a lot of people are unconscious
some are conscious but at the end the
day you get to choose you get to decide
am I gonna follow my path am I gonna
follow my divinity what am I willing to
do am i able to walk away from
everything I know to go into something
that's so much greater because I know
that there's something greater available
because I am a creator of my own life I
have sovereignty and I can go in and and
have any kind of reality and I choose to
live in a reality there's here's our
reality yeah so there are some people
who choose to live in a reality of
limitation that everything is a
coincidence I choose to live in a you
know reality just filled with
possibilities magic and joy that is my
choice and guess what it's been
manifesting so okay I'm gonna keep
living that possibilities magic and joy
that sounds like an amazing place that I
want to live in as well I do not like
living in limitations I don't like
living in fear I don't like living in in
things that restrict me from achieving
my divinity and my actualization and I
like helping people shatter through
those restrictions that they place on
themselves and reach their full
potential in their divinity so I like
the Marco Polo analogy I think that it
can live for a while until maybe there
is something that ends up being better
but there is definitely a polo the polo
is the same like you were saying for all
of us whether it's consciousness the
universe God the source source whatever
it may be that that is saying reach me
reach me reach your divine fullest
potential I'm here I'm ready for you I
will give you everything you could
possibly ever understand and even more
than that trust me trust me you will be
your maximal potential you'll be your
maximal being on this planet and so
that's good that is that's a lot of fun
and I'm glad that we got to unpack
reaching your divinity together that was
a lot of fun like you guys know if you
guys had a good time please write below
we'd love to hear your thoughts about
reaching your divinity also like
subscribe join us also don't just
consume this content go create with it
go write about it go make video about it
go start a company with it go build go
build go create go create
haha alright
we're so committed we are so committed
to helping everybody reach their full
potential and to be living the life that
they are meant that you were created to
live not what other people have been
telling you I know that I stand by it I
stand by him
actually no he sends in that too we are
you know
and it's those Trailblazers it's the
people that have those brave hearts and
their brave minds brave souls brave
voices are doing that too showing you
what's possible you guys anything is
possible I'm just so grateful to be on
this journey don't forget there will
always be the people that tell you to
try and tell you to stop and you've got
to keep going
you got to keep being that brave soul
and keep pushing forward to reach your
divinity and help others do the same
much love everyone peace